right  below and down to the right from the  moon i'm not sure which one that is but  i thought this was kind of a cool  looking image this is just past sunset  and i think this was taken two days ago  you can see the moon slowly changes  position because we're in lvlh  that's really nice shot there red  about half as nice as it looked out the  window  your eyes have a lot better  viewing capability in these  cameras in fact see some flashes at the  bottom of the screen that's a lightning  sperm going on down there below  ed where did you say you were over the  earth when this was going on  this was uh northern europe probably uh  northern central europe maybe around  ukraine or somewhere around there  i've been seeing these everywhere from  sort of uh  western europe all the way through to uh  north of mongolia  you